this week marked nine years since the
devastating earthquake and tsunami in
Japan the disaster triggered another
crisis a meltdown at the Fukushima
nuclear power plant more than 160,000
people fled the region along Japan's
northern coast and many have never
returned
CBS's Ramey Inocencio was given rare
access to the ghostly restricted area
surrounding the Fukushima plant
no this isn't Fukushima in 2011 this is
Japan's radiation devastated region now
people are allowed to pass through
quickly but still not allowed to live
here the beeping you're hearing is my
dosimeter going off it's telling me
we're getting exposed to ten times the
normal amount of radiation we are in the
no-go zone outside the nuclear power
plant people haven't been allowed to
live here for the past nine years and
buildings still look like this
in 2011 more than 18,000 people were
killed after a tremendous 9.0 earthquake
unleashed a towering 50-foot tsunami
triggering meltdowns in three reactors
that cut power and water to millions
maintenance and cleanup continue to this
day with the ruined reactors encased in
new containment shields to wall off
radiation tokyo electric power or TEPCO
which still runs the plant granted CBS
News rare access to show progress being
made
we geared up from socks to vests and our
own personal radiation counters we had
our baseline radiation levels check to
compare with when we leave then headed
out to the site of the world's worst
nuclear catastrophe since Chernobyl
we're about a hundred times normal
background radiation
techo employees say that this is safe as
long as we don't stay here very long
this past week a new movie about
Fukushima was released in time for this
anniversary retelling a disaster that
need is little to dramatize further
robots are only just starting to survey
damage done lethal radiation is still
generated by melted fuel inside but a
technological cleanup is decades away
another problem is political water
needed to cool the reactors is building
up and space is running out it's a not
in my backyard anxiety more than 1000
tanks hold more than 1.2 million tons of
tainted water that can fill nearly 500
Olympic sized swimming pools the most
pressing question now is what to do with
all of this treated water TEPCO says the
most realistic option is to release all
of it into the ocean and that it's safe
ken Jia Bay who taught us around is
Fukushima Daiichi is public relations
manager
we're thoroughly inspecting fish and can
confirm there's no fishery contamination
he says and if we precisely follow
national regulations on diluting water
when disposing of it there won't be any
problems it'd be perfectly fine to do I
call it controlled monitored release
American nuclear expert Lake Barrett
agrees he oversaw the us's Three Mile
Island nuclear accident and says Japan's
emotions still run high people are
basically healing themselves from the
emotion of the accident there is
distrust people feel the local harmful
rumors that people might not eat the
fish and there would be those concerns
and with Japan hosting the Summer
Olympics this year the torch relay is
scheduled to begin in the country just
minutes away from the nuclear plant what
do you tell people who are nervous about
coming to Japan Fukushima will be in the
spotlight says ah BAE we want to welcome
visitors with a credo of safety first
we're proceeding step by step toward
decommissioning I want visitors to be
assured of our steady clear progress
made so far towards that goal but that
goal will remain elusive for a
generation to come with the burden of
this historic cleanup
and a trauma of the past few countries
will ever know for CBS this morning
Saturday rainy innocencio Fukushima
Japan all that water sitting there and
what do you do yeah and this is
something that is gonna last again not
it's not over now this is years years
almost a decade later yeah